hey youtubers is Charlie we got to talk
about all those big spider-man reveals
what's going to be happening in the next
movie the stuff they've confirmed as
well as infinity war so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet this is going to be all about what's
coming next hopefully you guys have had
a chance to see the movie if you haven't
there's still a spider-man ticket
giveaway that I'm doing all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so there are a
couple key setups for the sequel and a
couple of implied things let's start
with the biggest thing first there's
like 7/10 things on my list here so the
sinister six they're very clearly
teasing that with the Scorpion
post-credit scene so far we have the bow
team woodbine shocker
the Scorpion Mac Gargan in the vulture
so they're going with a slightly
different roster we don't know where
Green Goblin dr. octopus the shocker the
other members of the classic sinister
six are in this universe the original
roster was vulture electro Kraven the
hunter the original Mysterio in Sandman
so there are a couple characters on that
list that we've never seen before
sony has talked about wanting to do a
Mysterio spin-off film at some point
they're doing that black cat silver
sable then a movie right now so I think
it just depends on how successful those
are but in the spirit of Kevin Feige
doing different things than they've done
in previous spider-man films I think
that the first characters they would
make a beeline for to introduce in that
sequel as part of the sinister six would
be Kraven the hunter and Mysterio in the
thing about the original version of
Mysterio is that he was a
special-effects wizard that just made
things look like magic so it works
perfectly for Hollywood because it's all
about big special effects but because
that's an awful lot of characters to
tease out in a two-and-a-half-hour movie
they might just introduce a couple of
new characters and then have the
sinister six team up at the very end of
that movie for whatever third movie that
Marvel and Sony end up making when they
refine their sharing arrangement there's
still a few really big things behind the
scenes that are dictating how things go
in the spider-man universe Tom Holland
wants to play him for ten years but it
just depends on what Sony wants to do
with what Marvel wants to do in how they
continue to share the character in the
MCU so for the most part Kevin Feige the
powers-that-be has said that there's not
going to be anything that's going to
change going forward so they'll reach
some sort of new finance
deal and they'll be able to do sinister
six they'll be able to do all the
classic characters like Green Goblin
Doctor Octopus they'll just get to it
eventually but for the most part the
sinister six of the MCU will be born
from the weapons the vulture was selling
so there was all kinds of Easter eggs in
the background they were building
weapons for eight years so it makes
sense that scorpion Mysterio these other
characters got their weapons from the
vulture at some point there's still that
black market trade that's going on they
weren't the only shop in town they were
just one of the big ones in the New York
area just because vulture is in prison
doesn't mean the people are going to
stop trading in illegal alien weapons
and remembered Santos in his black order
are coming to earth so there's just like
a whole new wave of alien tech and
destruction that's going to rain down so
just means more stuff for the black
market trade to take advantage of but
the new suit at the end of the movie big
teaser right is basically the iron
spider it looks a lot like all-new
all-different just like slightly
brighter shinier the color scheme is a
little bit weird it looks more metallic
more armored like a classic Iron Man
suit for the most part if we do see him
in that I think that's going to be
specific to the Avengers films and when
he's in his own spider-man films he'll
just be wearing the classic looking
version of the suit and continue to
unlock features and learn how to use
them better with the help of suit lady
Karen Jennifer Connelly the wife of
Jarvis she was one of the best parts of
the movie all Karen thanks so much it's
so good to have someone to talk to one
of the biggest laughs in the theater was
when he did the big monument save and he
was hanging upside down and Liz Allen
was sitting there and Karen said now's
your moment Peter kiss her before they
pull the rug out from under him and he
falls down the shaft mostly meant to be
a joke on the kiss in that first
spider-man film but you see how good
they can use that AI for comedy so
they'll continue to do that quite a bit
and because Peter is actually going to
get to meet Hulk and Thor for real hey
it's great to finally meet you guys
I thought you'd be more handsome in
person and then later in the movie when
they make fun of them when Karen starts
replaying the footage and you catch him
impersonating them in the mirror with
the fake hammer
they'll be follow up moments like that
because he's actually going to meet them
during infinity war so it'll change his
relationship with them they'll just
continue to have funny moments
impersonating
them and play-acting big scenes that
they shared together during the really
huge Avengers movies the next big thing
is that may WTF reaction at the end so
now that she knows she'll just continue
to flip out every time she sees
something spider-man related on the news
the Peter's not going to stop being
spider-man
so it'll change their relationship but
she's not going to start helping him out
but they might give her a badass moment
where the sinister six characters find
out where he lives
maybe she gets roped into some of their
plot but because she's not an old lady
she actually gets to stand up for
herself and have some badass moment so
her knowing just implies that she'll
become more involved whether she wants
to or not but she's not going to be like
Ned the guy in the chair so nedley's
will continue to be the guy in the chair
just have funny moments with Peter one
of the other biggest lapse in my theater
but the other big thing is the Miles
Morales tease my nephew lives in this
neighborhood I don't want these weapons
around here so Donald Glover's Prowler
character will continue to show up but
he's still pretty small-time he just
wants to hold people up I don't want to
blast them back in time so just because
Peter is so young Myles is super young
so if he doesn't appear they'll just
continue to tease him out but he's so
far away from the spider bite that if we
ever see ultimate spider-man Miles
Morales in this universe it'll be like
six seven eight years down the road
it'll be a long ways away but I know
everyone's really talking about Oscorp
in the big characters so they sold the
Avengers Tower that would be the place
to put a score Peter spends most of his
time in Queens and because he's in high
school that's why he's so local to there
they said that was a big thing and
showing spider-man in the suburbs like
how would he deal with that that's why
they had that funny Ferris Bueller
sequence where he's running across the
golf course like there's literally
nothing for him to swing across but
there was also a bit of a teaser for
Zendaya's Michelle character at the end
where she says Peter where are you going
just kidding I don't care
but then she looks up like yeah she
totally cares where he's going in there
a couple moments during the film where
she makes jokes about not being a
stalker because she keeps tabs on Peter
every once in a while so very clearly
she's interested in him
and because she's teased as being this
really smart person will probably learn
his identity and they'll just continue
to tease out chemistry between the two
of them they're not going to get
supermodel
with it but they'll just continue to
push those characters together
she might wind up helping him out in
some way but I think they're trying to
change Peters relationship with his
traditional love interest so you know
Mary Jane was a traditional girlfriend
for him she was a model she didn't
really get to do that many cool things
so I think they're trying to change that
with the new films so it'll be fun to
see how they deal with that and they've
also said really like the last big thing
is that there will be another Avenger in
the movie like Iron Man was in this
movie they didn't say who was going to
be but it'll be a big a-list Avenger so
that could be one of the New Avengers
because the next spider-man movie is
dropping right after minutes after
Avengers 4 meaning that we'll have our
Captain Marvel fully powered in this
universe will still have ant-man we'll
have the Hulk we'll have vision who
knows what happens to Scarlet Witch
during the infinity war movies but I
think it'd be more realistic that they
put a human character in the movie and
it'll either be Bruce Banner or it'll be
Captain America because I think those
are Peters heroes his classic heroes he
was impersonating them in the mirror and
think about the way they used Iron Man
it was a little bit of comedy there so
like say they use Hulk
it'll be Bruce Banner for most of the
film but then they'll have the funny WTF
moment where he fully Hulk's out and
helps spider-man in a big jam but like
Ironman in this film he was barely in
there he makes in the suit he helps him
out a couple times but really you follow
Peter through the whole film so
whichever Avenger it ends up being it'll
be the same deal and it just feels like
because Peter is such a science bro and
training it would make sense that you
put the other science bro from the
Avengers in the movie so Bruce Banner
would be the first go to well let me
know in the comments which Avenger do
you want them to put in the movie and
what's going to happen is is they
confirmed a big a really big thor
ragnarok character so i'm going to do a
video for that next it should post in a
couple hours but leave all your requests
in the comments below I will do
spider-man Easter eggs in the next
couple days too but congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner bagel angels
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my post credit scene video and you can
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight